مع استمرار الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا ،
هناك دفعة يائسة
لحماية المواقع التاريخية والثقافية في أوكرانيا ،
تطلب الأمم المتحدة من السلطات الأوكرانية وضع علامة على
المباني الرئيسية بهذا الشعار الأزرق.
نحن الآن سعداء جدًا برؤيتك ،
شكرًا لك على استضافتي ، شكرًا لك ،
أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكانك إخبارنا
بالضرر المؤكد الذي
حدث بالفعل للمواقع التراثية
في أوكرانيا حتى الآن
من التقارير التي
نتلقاها من الأرض لك  تعرف من
جهة الاتصال الخاصة بنا من المهنيين
الذين قرروا البقاء في معظم
المدن ،
فأنا أعني
أن الوضع مدمر حقًا
أكثر من
30 من المعالم والمواقع التاريخية التي
تم تأكيد تضررها تمامًا
من مدن معينة مثل
خاركيف ولكن أيضًا في شيرني في جينيفيف من أجل
على سبيل المثال ، يبدو أن المركز التاريخي
قد قُتل
بالكامل وهذا حقًا وضع رهيب
لأنه لا أحد يعرف  عذرًا ، إذا تم استعادة كل هذه
المباني التاريخية
والتراث الثقافي
مرة أخرى ، فأنا أعني
أنها معقدة ورائعة عندما
ننظر إلى هذه الصور ، فمن
الصعب تصديق أن محاولة
إصلاح أو إعادة بناء أي مما
تعرفه أمر ممكن.  نظرًا لأنك على
اتصال بالعديد من المسؤولين هناك أو
ثقافيًا تعرف المؤسسات أو
قادة مثل هذه الأماكن هناك في أوكرانيا ،
أعني هل شعورهم أن هذه
المباني الثلاثين التي ذكرتها كانت
مستهدفة بشكل مباشر أم أنها
عشوائية وأنهم
تضرروا  ودُمروا أه فقط
بسبب هذا الاستهداف غير
المنتظم للصواريخ ،
كما تعلمون ،
لن يكون من السهل اليوم معرفة بالضبط
أسباب استهدافهم
أو
تدميرهم ولكن حقيقة
أنهم دمروا و  هذه
خسارة فادحة
وأعتقد أه
نستمر في مراقبة الوضع
باستخدام صور الأقمار الصناعية لدينا بل وأيضاً
تقاريرنا لأناس من الأرض ونحن
تخشى أن يكون هذا
أسوأ في المستقبل إذا استمر هذا
التصعيد في العنف و / أو
والقتال وبينما ذكرت سابقًا
أن اليونسكو تحاول أن تعرف
تقوية حماية هذه المواقع من
خلال أه وضعها وطلبها.
يتم وضع الشعارات الزرقاء على المباني ،
يعني أنك تأمل في
أن يتم احترام تلك الشعارات ولكن بعد ذلك
رأينا بالفعل أنك تعرف مبنى
به علامات على وجود أطفال
بالداخل من الهواء يمكنهم رؤيته
أنه قد يكون هناك  كن أطفالًا في الداخل
ولا يبدو أن هذا مهم كما
تعلم للروس
، هل أنت واثق من أن تلك
العلامات الزرقاء ستحترم ،
فأنت تعلم أن
هذا الشعار مهم جدًا لأن
هذه
الشعارات يجب وضعها في جميع المعالم التاريخية
لمجرد
أنك تعرف روسيا
ووقعت أوكرانيا على
الصكوك الدولية لحماية
التراث الثقافي في حالة النزاع ، لذلك
إذا كان
أي مبنى يحمل هذا الشعار وكان
مستهدفًا
أو مستهدفًا  بسبب الأضرار الجانبية ،
فهذا يعني أن أولئك الذين فعلوا ذلك
هم المسؤولون ويمكن نقلهم إلى
جوستين ويمكن اعتبار ذلك
أيضًا جريمة حرب في المستقبل